league of legal is sponsored by
curiosity stream and nebula get 26
off using the link in the description
liberals want to evict an elderly
financially troubled covent survivor and
his family from inner city public
housing
i mean that's only a bad take because it
doesn't say that the liberals also want
to
take away that elderly coveted
survivor's health care as well
well we're finally on the other side of
an incredibly momentous
election but at times it was a little
touch and go and while we know the
outcome now
along the way there were some how do i
put this charitably
bad election takes but now that
hindsight is 2020
why don't we engage in a little shot in
freudia and
let's make fun of some really bad
election opinions because not all
election opinions are created equal so
let's take a look at some of the worst
election takes out there
yeah so many of my friends were
completely thirsty
for chart throbb himself steve kornacki
or
korsnaki as i heard him referred to many
times
steve you are doing it for me done
with these numbers wait a minute let's
take out the old trusty couch
did this [ __ ] just pull out
steve
hey steve hey steve you ain't got to do
it all cuz
i'm not in any place to uh to opine on
that uh i'm not saying that steve
kornacki
is not hot what i am saying is that
lawyers are familiar
with um a phenomenon called the
deposition
effect a deposition is where you're
stuck in the same room
for hours where you're questioning a
witness there is opposing counsel and
the stenographer usually in the same
room
back when we could do things in the same
room and it wasn't all virtual and
one of the effects of the deposition is
that because you're locked in a room
with that person
multiple people for many hours at a time
you
have build up an affinity for these
people whether it's opposing council or
the stenographer and
uh they might seem uh more attractive
than they did
when you first entered that room look
i'm not saying that that's the case with
steve kornacki but i'm just saying you
know sleep on it and
ask yourself if you still feel that way
in the morning
[Laughter]
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
all right the king of banned election
takes himself donald trump saying that
he's going to go straight to the supreme
court and i hate to break it to him but
as
avid viewers of this channel know that's
generally not how these things work the
us supreme court is the highest court in
the federal system though
when it comes to state law often it is
the state supreme court that is the
highest and uh last word on the subject
but
generally you don't go straight to the
united states supreme court and it can
take a very very long time to get there
in fact
even when the court is moving fast like
we saw with bush versus gore in 2000 it
can take over a month before it actually
gets to the united states supreme court
though
interestingly donald trump is not as off
as he usually is
in this respect because occasionally
under extremely rare circumstances the
court can weigh in on emergency relief
applications and here
justice alito did issue an injunctive
order saying that
the state of pennsylvania should follow
basically the guidance of the secretary
of the commonwealth which
seems like everyone was doing anyway
but of course this order from justice
alito on the supreme court uh
engendered its own bad take in the form
of this tweet from
sean spicer who's saying that basically
this order from justice alito was a game
changer and
will basically change the outcome of the
election in pennsylvania that's not how
that happens and in fact it seems like
there are a very very small number of
ballots that came
in after the statutory deadline that
might be in this
small grace period created by the courts
and in fact it seems like
the state of pennsylvania was already
doing that they were segregating the
ballots
they were counting the ballots but not
adding them to the cumulative total for
the state and waiting for the courts to
figure out
what they're going to do with these
provisional ballots uh so it's
not going to change the outcome sorry
sean spicer
ah yes who could forget the near
simultaneous
chanting from the crowds of trump
supporters some saying to stop the count
and
others saying that we needed to count
the votes look they have a first
amendment right to protest the things
that they are aggrieved about but at the
same time it seems
ironic at the very least that they would
at least some would argue
for this anti-democratic measure of
stopping the counting of the actual
ballots or
at least the processing of the ballots
now in fairness
i think this is a little bit blown out
of proportion because the laws of
different states are different there is
no universal election
law throughout this country so what's
legal in one state
might not be legal in another state but
still it's a bad look when you're out
there protesting against the counting of
the votes themselves while the same time
another group of trump supporters are
arguing the exact opposite thing
bad election take
yeah the pollsters got this one pretty
wrong the polls
showed that joe biden was going to win
in the landslide and that the democrats
were going to pick up potentially many
seats in the senate and take
a majority in the senate and that of
course never happened
the pollsters learned from their
mistakes in 2016 where they were off by
an average of five percent
they revised their models they did their
homework and in 2020
they were off by over seven percent now
in fairness they did get some things
right
apparently arizona and virginia are
pretty close to the way that the
pollsters
predicted things would go but across the
country they were incredibly wrong
the posters got it knowingly wrong they
got it knowingly wrong
knowingly wrong as if they were doing
everyone a favor by
suggesting that the the democrats were
going to win
in the landslide you could argue it both
ways i suppose that
it might suppress the vote or people
might not go out and vote because they
think that it's going to be a landslide
that's what some people say about 2016
but but there's no doubt that
the polls in general saying that it was
going to be a complete bloodbath we're
uh
we're very wrong
i feel i would be remiss if i didn't
include uh
q anon as a world-class bad take
because i'm sorry uh the military didn't
uh get operationalized uh as far as i
know all my friends were not
sent to guantanamo bay and q has been
incredibly silent
now that trump is no longer going to be
re-elected
you know frankly i miss good
old-fashioned conspiracy theories that
were harder to debunk they weren't
making uh pronouncements about what
would and would not happen on certain
days it could easily be disproven i
missed the old conspiracy theories like
the black helicopters and the chemtrails
i mean those were
at least general enough that uh there
was no
certainty that things were were not
going to happen you and i need to try
harder it's sad that they got the
election so so wrong and that
no one is in jail
uh a donald trump tweet from 2012 where
he says the electoral college is a
disaster for
democracy i guess this is a bad take
with respect to him
losing the election in this year but i
actually i think that's absolutely right
the electoral college is a disaster for
democracy just because
the popular vote happened to line up
with the electoral college vote
uh in 2020 does not mean that it's a
good institution and then there are all
kinds of anti-democratic issues
with the electoral college i've covered
that in uh several videos in the past
but frankly given the fact that it's
possible
that faithless electors could screw up
the results and and
how the votes are wildly
disproportionate
uh the electoral college definitely
needs uh some work
this is probably the funniest thing that
has ever happened
in american politics but probably full
stop because
it was not the case the trump
administration was holding a press
conference
at the four seasons hotel in
philadelphia the four seasons tweeted
out that in fact
they were not holding the press
conference there and then the trump
surrogates mobilized and held a press
conference in front of
four seasons total landscaping in a
run-down
industrial part of philadelphia just on
a whim credit where credit is due
they got their stuff together and held a
press conference in a place that
should not have had a press conference
in between a crematorium
and an adult sex toy store you literally
could not make that up if the writers
had written that for veep they would
have rejected it as
too crazy you know what i kind of love
it
probably the funniest thing that has
ever happened in american politics
and ever actually chanting fox news
sucks fox news sucks the reason why
they're chanting that is because fox
news
called arizona for biden yesterday
and a lot of people are angry about that
it's incredible that so many people on
the right were apoplectic that
fox news called arizona for joe biden
now granted it
was early on in the process but it
couldn't have had any effect on the
election they didn't call it until
after the polls were closed as it turns
out fox news was right so
obviously the damage uh could not have
actually existed because
it turns out that arizona did go for joe
biden but that's the irony of the facts
don't care about your feelings crowd
pat toomey the senator from pennsylvania
as well as others were rightfully
complaining that pennsylvania
didn't start counting the mailed in
ballots and other ballots
until election day and thus the counting
process
in pennsylvania was long and drawn out
and that's that's perfectly fine but
the reason it was long and drawn out is
because of state law
state law mandated that they couldn't
start uh counting those ballots
a lot of other states including florida
start
way ahead of time so that they don't
have this backlog of
ballots that are uncounted and that can
stretch out until long after election
day
and in pennsylvania it was a republican
house of representatives that refused to
pass legislation to change that law
we're all exasperated about how long it
takes in all the different states
including pennsylvania but you've got to
change the law to be able to handle that
and under kovit
you would think that they would want to
do that but of course they did not
liberals want to evict an elderly
financially troubled covent survivor and
his family from inner city public
housing
i mean that's only a bad take because it
doesn't say that the liberals also want
to
take away that elderly coveted
survivor's health care as well
and back to donald trump quoting the
illustrious former acting attorney
general matthew whitaker
we need an explanation as to how these
numbers have been running up for the
last two or three days well
it seems pretty simple number one the
president said people should not
vote by mail democrats often said that
they should
vote by mail the vote by mail tends to
favor the democrats in the first place
and of course there's the issue that
when
another vote comes in that adds to the
count that's
called math and on top of that the count
continues so
as a lot of people were pointing out on
election day we're not going to have a
final count so
it takes a long time to process these
things and lots of states have laws that
say that
as long as the ballot is postmarked by
election day that
the ballot itself can come in many days
or weeks later and still be counted so
um
that's the answer
no state authority nor fec has yet to
declare the winner yet fox news just
called it for joe biden
wow yeah that's uh that's sort of how
that works the calling of a presidential
election is
mainly just a media thing the fec
doesn't make the call
nor does fox news in general that's sort
of just a projection doesn't actually
carry any legal weight with it so rudy
giuliani was also saying that the court
would have to decide
uh who was the president that's also not
how that works the court might decide
the lawsuits which is probably what he
was hinting at but
it's not for a court to declare anyone
the president or not
it's just a media thing that they say
based on the uh the results that who's
the projected winner
funny how cnn has suddenly stopped its
kovetkovic kovetkovit drumbeat isn't it
yeah maybe my timeline is just different
from other people's but
my timeline on twitter at least was
filled with so many people talking about
a hundred and ten hundred and twenty
hundred and thirty thousand new
covid cases a day exactly the same time
that they were talking about the
election and of course
the election is relatively consequential
for kovid so uh it makes sense that
kovit was sort of crowded out for like a
day or two kovid never left my timeline
and i'm still
stuck at home
ben shapiro arguing every legally cast
vote should be counted every illegally
cast vote should not end of story
well everyone agrees with that but a lot
of the
litigation itself or at least the
posturing over the litigation is over
what is considered a legal vote or not
you could make the same argument in 2000
in bush versus gore but when you're
talking about
the law about whether it permits a
recount or not or whether
a hanging chad or a vote made with a
marker versus a pen
is legally cast or not you're changing
the
the rules as with respect to what is
legally cast or not so that's sort of
the beginning of the fight not the end
of the fight and what has got to be one
of the
worst election takes of all time from
former football player and i think
american gladiator participant
herschel walker says instead of us
fighting and going to court why don't we
have nevada arizona georgia north
carolina pennsylvania michigan and
wisconsin vote again
we can have it done within a week and
maintain our democracy
my god apart from that violating the
election laws of all of those states
there would be rioting in the street can
we just can we not be done with the the
2020 election
uh which some are saying is a
continuation of the 2016 election my god
that's insane complete insanity
but of course even that election take
can't hold a candle to the ultimate bad
take
tweeted by none other than the big man
himself donald trump
saying i won this election by a lot
exclamation point
spoiler alert he did not i think donald
trump is just a practitioner
of uh the secret uh he's just putting it
out there trying to
will it into existence but uh
unfortunately i don't think that's going
to be enough in this election
that's the truth so those are the worst
election takes that i could find and if
you're the kind of person that loves
dunking on terrible legal takes
i tackle a couple more over at nebula
this tweet seems
perfectly normal the only problem is the
time stamp
november 10th a full week after the
november election
i posted a whole extended version of
this video there on nebula as well
because sometimes even legal issues are
too hot for youtube which is why my
creator friends teamed up to build our
own platform where
we don't have to worry about
demonetization or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream nebula is a place where
creators can do what they do best
create it's a place where we can house
our content ad-free and also experiment
with original content and new series
that probably wouldn't work on youtube
in fact almost all the videos i put up
on nebula are both ad-free
or have an extended discussion or have
bloopers or some extra content they're
also released early before the youtube
version nebula features a lot of
youtube's top educationalist creators
like
real engineering tier zoo and kento
bento and we also get to collaborate in
ways that probably wouldn't work on
youtube and put out amazing original
content like lindsey ellis's documentary
about
whether blazing saddles could be made
today real engineering's
incredible multi-part series about the
logistics of d-day and
alex nicholls show alex goes bananas
where older millennials try to explain
things to this sheltered gen z kid like
lim biscuit
will smith or the episode that i guess
star in trying to explain
the whole gwen stefani thing have you
ever heard of ska
not at all so what does this have to do
with curiosity stream well as the go-to
source for the best documentaries on the
internet
they love educational content and
educational creators and we worked out a
deal where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with the link in the description
you'll also get a nebula subscription
for free and to be clear that nebulous
subscription is not a trial it's free
for as long as you're a curiosity stream
member and for a limited time curiosity
stream is offering
26 off of their annual plans that's less
than 15
per year for both curiosity stream and
nebula and because i'm a lawyer
i made sure that the 26 off is by
contract the best deal you'll find
anywhere so if you click the link in the
description you'll get both curiosity
stream and nebula for 26
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle
it's a great way to support this channel
and educational content directly for
just 14.79 per year so just click on the
link in the description
or go to curiositystream.com legally
clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my trashing of these election
bad takes are there election bad takes
that i missed that i should have trashed
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with
all of my other real lawyer reactions
and my meme reviews and all the good
stuff over here so
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court